our next speaker is Thomas Milan from
also University let's get to them right
here and he's going to talk about
ancestral population genomics will call
isn't it not long yep microphone on yeah
so I'd say I think the time a little bit
little bit here because it's going to be
about the sequential mark of core listen
it's just we call that coalesced and
hidden Markov models he knows because we
didn't really know what that is what we
were doing when we started doing it but
yeah I get into that so point okay but
starting here with the coalescent the
multi species correlation and the
observations where all of this ancestral
population genomics comes from which is
as you all know unless we've seen in in
a million talks not today but all over
the place the last couple of years if
you look at different species and you
look at the sequence is comparing them
you'll get a gene tree which is the blue
thing in here which may or may not look
like the species to you which is the the
brown thing here and the reason that
things are not always looking similar is
this population genetics that's going on
in the species
whenever you're picking individual genes
they're in individuals from some species
and if you trace the history back from a
single gene today back to the past
whenever you find a speciation split
like like like here if you have picked
while two genes from the same population
or from from from different different
species the genes can be in the same
individual when you hit this PCA I think
it'd be too different and if they're two
different what they're likely to be if
you've picked a gene from two different
species then you have the coalescent
process going on up here and you have to
go further back in
until you find the most recent common
ancestor which leaves sometime between
the species split and and the population
split and if you are interested in
finding out something about speciation
when does it occur and things like that
you'll have essentially two problems if
you look at fossils those will be lower
bounds for for speciation space because
what you look at is this fossil does
that have derived characteristic air
that that matches one species rather
than the other so you get some lower
bound but if you look at the DG's you'll
always get an upper bound so if you're
just interested in finding the species
time you have a problem this is what we
want this is what we can what we can get
but of course we have our published
engineer theory that tells us how to
gene sample from ancestral population
we'll find a common a common ancestor in
the simplest simplest model which is the
guy here we can pick two two genes one
from each species trace them back
instead of the species time and then
just say from that point on you have the
coalescent process which means you have
to wait some exponentially distributed
time until you find the most most recent
common ancestor and if you could just go
and sample pairs of jeans again and
again and again you could get this
distribution and it's very easy to
figure out when the populations split
into what would later become the two
species because that's just the the
point here where the exponential
distribution starts of course you can't
do that and this is the reason why you
can't do that in any meaningful I would
say definition of the species you can't
really have that two individuals in the
same species one is closer to another
species then then the other one not if
well not in general anyway so if you're
looking at two different species most
likely if you pick to give two different
genes so two
same with truth the same the same gene
to different individuals and trace them
back they will find a an ancestor within
the species they ascended from and then
you go back and doesn't matter how often
your sample you get the same sample size
up here speciation where you are way
we're interested in in sampling form so
you can pick all the pairs you want down
here won't matter it's the same two
genes you're looking at up here so
you're trying to do statistics from one
observation really they set for
recombination if you take a single gene
you actually get a lot of samples up
there
it's just along that along the genome
you can't pick you can't pick two
different samples down here and look at
that changes in coalescent time but you
can look along the genome and that will
at the talent appreciation really be in
a lot of different individuals as you
trace just one sample back it's going to
be split up and if your final back it's
essentially sampling from the entire
population up there so if you pick an
alignment of two two genomes and scan
along you will see this process going on
and you're essentially sampling your
pairs of genes
you're just sampling them along the
sequence rather than going and finding
different different pairs running it
again and again and if you want more
species it's the same it's the same
process again now you also observe in
completely need sorting if you have
closely related species which for for
for great apes pretty must mean
everywhere you look there's a little bit
of in completely resulting for human
chimps and gorillas there's actually
quite a lot so you see these different
different topologies as you scan along
and this approach to scanning along is
what leads to these sequential
coalescent models instead of simulating
or analyzing the sequences back in time
waiting for them to call this a
recombine or whatever they want to do
you run along the sequence and saying
they had these recombination events and
coalescence going on these are
sequential models and little history of
that starts in 99 this history might
actually be yeah incorrect I might be
forgetting papers and things like that
but I've tried to find everything that I
think it's relevant in there if people
disagree that you shut up then I'll
update the slides for next time yes you
and I have editor and it's to one of the
graphs later but I think the first
people who did this idea of modeling the
coalescence as a sequential process
rather than a temporal one was a custom
view of annual Hine and what they did
was essentially saying okay if I start
at the left most part of the of the gene
I'm interested in and run along then
after a certain wallet should see a
recombination then I picked the
recombination somewhere on my tree pull
that apart now I have something split
splitting and now I need to call this
that thing begging to my genealogist
somewhere and then I take another jump
and I have to pick somewhere on my
genealogy a recombination trace that up
somewhere and coalescing and and so on
which will give you the ancestor
recombination graph you you you it's
actually the same leaf from exactly the
same model as if you were settling back
in time which also means that you end up
with this terribly complex structure the
ancestor recombination graph which grows
there very fast as you scan along there
that you really can only handle very
very short segments but then
and I I'm pretty sure this is this is
where this started the idea came that
well if you're going to pick a
recombination in the current genealogy
and then coalescing it in you can just
you can all everything to the left of
the sequence I'm scanning along and only
cool is it into the current gene LM gene
elegy I'm looking at that means I don't
have to keep track of all these ranges
over here where I can call this in it
means that recombination stat hips hits
trap material essentially ignored but
you get a Markov process which makes
this computationally much much simpler
to work with you just pick on the
genealogy some some point put a
recombination there and then coalesce it
in some some somewhere else and you have
yet you have a change in your local
geniality and you get a if you if you do
all the calculations you'll get a
transition probability saying what's the
probability on seeing this genealogy on
the right if I have this one on the left
and there's two variations of this one
is called the SMC the sequential mark of
coalescing this is SMC prime the
difference between the two is the first
one says you can't reek
well you can't coalesce things that
don't have overlapping ancestral
material the other says you can in in
one-on-one sense so if you have a
genealogy right like like this and I put
a recombination here then that means
that whatever I have on this line is
here and the line I pulled off here
looks like this these two can't coalesce
because they don't have overlapping as
just one material this is where the
recombination was
but actually you'll still get a mark of
property if you call this back into to
the line where you started and how much
that really matters I guess depends a
lot on how likely it is that you call
this back into your lineage but if you
only have a few ladies here that's
that's very likely if you have a sample
of one for example it's very likely that
what you will call this into is where
you started if you remember the earlier
slide if you're modeling species for
millions of years you might only have a
single sample and you want to model that
so if you assume that I can recombine
somewhere in here but then I can't call
this bag in whenever there was an early
recombination you're getting it all
wrong because you're saying they won't
call this back what's they're very
likely to do with this is millions of
years if you want to look at very long
periods of time with the single sale you
wonder do you want this one but
otherwise I don't think that's so much
difference between the two anyway we
like yeah we had read the papers we
didn't think about that much because
we'd also read the view often high on
paper so we only thought okay you can
mark this stuff as a sequential
sequential process so if you have a
sequential process and you want to do
inference on genomes you you build a
hidden Markov model that's pretty much
that's that's always good advice and
back in 2006 and 7 we did that we didn't
think too much about the coalescent
process sorts just that we wanted to
model these changing genealogies and
then based on how they actually changed
try to pull out some some some
information though we just said okay you
can have these well really we were
looking at human ships and
and gorillas so you have a sample of
three there's three possible genealogies
but they're not equally likely because
in in the species tree you have a period
of time where only humans and chimps can
coalesce and then you have a symmetric
thing up here where you have three
different trees and they're all equally
equally likely so we modeled at us one
genealogy that colas is here and then
three up here which is not really our
idea this has been around for for for
for a while so the one we weren't being
that clever about it these are just the
genealogies we were picked and then we
said okay we can build a colors and
hidden Markov model scale along there
the g---men we for a guy like that you
just need transition probabilities and
we put some constraints on the
transitions saying okay these these are
the constraints that we believe are
there we were wrong there should have
been some others but we didn't do the
call isn't math at the time we just
picked these transitions and then we
scanned along and then we picked the
maximum likelihood estimates and then
from there we could work our way back to
split times and a 50 position
but of course quickly people told us
there you can actually calculate these
transition probabilities from the
coalescent and then get the right
transition probabilities now given by
the parameters of the model you actually
inserted in and if you do that you get
other constraints but you can do it and
then just based on recombination rates
and effective publication sizes and
things like that you can calculate the
likelihood of that thing just running
the Dakotas America model along and
something we republished in 2009 there
we actually got this oh this thing yeah
wrong so so we said that you can have a
a recombination along this this long
line but once it's there
have to coalesce into something some
something else but uh but it was
essentially taking the ESM C model and
building there that they hidden marking
from that jumping between these four
four genie religions but it's not the
only thing you can get out of this
coalescing process because if you pick
just two genes and look at their
ancestry is they're going to be split
apart and coalesce and that gives you
different coalescence collisions times
not jumping between different trees that
have the same topology but the branch
lengths change so if you can scan along
you will see your code s and time here
jump up there and jump here and see this
thing going on and in a couple of people
that look at that we need a simple model
in 2010/11 where we we build a model as
saying okay you Joe you run along a pair
you can probably know where pairwise is
SMC it's the same model XE that's the
next mix line by pylean Durban nervous
yeah
it's the same model and at the same time
the idea is you only have two genes and
you can model there the time they call
it and then you have to discretize time
but if you do that you have a finite
state space for a hidden Markov model
and then you can run along along with
that and then based on the parameters
that generates the decision probability
you can pull out information we only
looked at a split time in isolation
model for those four rango tanks the
early and urban model this it's smaller
because they pick a lot of different
time intervals and then they look at how
if if I parameter this call isn't rate
inside them and let that very freely
pretty much then I can take the inverse
of that and kept the effective
population to
out of any time period back in time from
from these from these pears but the way
I see it they're both they're both the
idea of taking their core lesson of
pears building a hidden Markov model and
then scanning along down so locally here
with a new songs group they were simply
doing their the same thing but trying to
get more more sampled so the two other
models they are looking at pears if you
want to know something about the reason
that the recent past you need a larger
sample size because there's not really a
lot going on in the recent past in in
the coolest so they were building
essentially a pairwise model but
combined with a sampling approach where
you sort of pick so you have a you have
a set of chromosomes that don't coalesce
that's it it's just they stretched back
forever and then you take the pairwise
coalesce and let a new new chromosome
coalesce into into these so they can hit
more and the single sample in the
pairwise coalescent but they don't model
the the actual genealogy of this sample
you need to do a little bit because you
need to take into account that the
correlation rate actually decreases as
you go back in time because these would
have caught a list but it's not
explicitly explicitly modeled and then
the history lesson continues so this is
as far as I know the the current graph
of ideas coming coming out of this so
this stuff I talked about the sequential
process and then making it Markov
we had the two for topology of 440
energies here
this is the stuff I've been working on
which is a PS
you have the pairwise sequential Markov
here the yeast
I think the published stuff from from
you right yeah that that's the three
papers here that all says 2013 they're
not actually published in 2013 I don't
think any of them are published yet this
one you can find on archive it's Adam C
Berlin they sampled arcs in an MC MC
approach it is the idea of running along
with with a marker model combined with
the idea of picking a new chromosome
that you can call s into the genealogy
you've already already seen shivers and
Durban's that's taking the pairwise
coalescing and making it multiple the
question mark of coal is so it's sort of
tough that idea a screwball Daniela
Jensen the they've written a paper that
compares these different approaches to
making a mark of coalition-building
the sequential mark of women without
these diamonds and also taken into
account that maybe you can actually call
this and will recombine cullism and so
on for a number of times along along
bonds but this is a theoretical paper on
it that will be out in theoretical
population genetics soonish it's already
online but I don't think it's out yet
this is I think models that are looking
at recent demographics we are looking at
a speciation that's sort of phobia
trying to do and now there's two things
I want to talk about for the last part
there's actually one thing I really
wanted to talk about that I haven't
actually managed to get to work yet so
I'm not going there I'm going to talk
about something else and then our newest
result which is let's see when that pops
up okay so I want to talk about how we
construct these things because you can
you can do the math and how these
topologies should should should change
but you can also just build a computer
program that does all of it for you
which is the approach that we've taken
and I'll describe it in a setting where
you can have two different populations
and you can have migration well you can
have any number for relations but you
can have migrations between them and
then if you want to model several
species you need to put that into your
model explicitly by saying okay at some
point I'm going to merge two populations
and then just do the same at the
Mattocks again with with a smaller set
of populations we imagine something like
like like like this we have a fixed
number of populations and there's
migration between and since this place
is on supposed to be about cavity the
resident computer science I'm happy to
show you a coloured pitcher net which is
something from theoretical computer
science that I've worked with ten years
ago and recently found a useful you can
model this process of having a leader
just going back and jumping between
populations and coalescing and
recombining as a colored pitcher and
essentially what you do is you put all
your lineage is down in in one place and
these lineages you represent as being
from some population so you check them
with the population they're in and then
they have nucleotides on the Left
genealogy that's going to be a
a set of those that have coalesced here
you start out with the single time and
then you had the same one on the right
so you have this Tribble a coalescent
will pick up two lineages so left and
right and left and right from two
lineages and have to be in the same
population P and then they're going to
put down something in the same
population but when you take the union
of the two left them and write sets so
that Curless is that if you do a
recombination your pick up something I
left and right and what you put back is
the left
combined with the empty set or the empty
set combined with the writer and M sit
combined with the right in the same
population so that splits the left and
right sets and migration just picked
something up and put it down in another
anymore population so if you take a
graph like this it's an ancestor
recombination graph for two nucleotides
you would represent the states along the
way like like this you start out with
for each of your samples you have one
lineage that has both the left and the
right nucleotide together and then a
recompose the coalescent makes these
unions the recombination split something
into the left and the inter said in the
end you said on the right so you go back
so some run through this this transition
system corresponds to an assister
recombination graph of two nucleotides
and if you pick two nucleotides and look
at the full state space it's going to
look like this these are the possible
states and transitions you can have and
again one run through it from the
initial state which is up there down to
one of these two once you're down here
you can't move back again
that's they've all coalesced and they
are on the same chromosome on two
different chromosomes you can circle
around here and any run through this
corresponds to an ancestral
recombination graph this is what it
looks like if you have three well let's
let's
a lot of these runs will give you the
same the same to local genealogist
you'll get the same joke or lesson trees
because whenever you run in a cycle in
here they jump from here to here and
then back again you are actually looking
at these invisible events or migrations
so you can migrate in self ablation then
you can might migrate back that doesn't
actually show up in the genealogy or you
can recombine and then coalesce again
that is in the arc but you can't observe
it so if you only want the interesting
gene elegies you can split this graph
into the strongly connected components
that's states where you can get from all
state to any other within within the set
these corresponds any any one through
these corresponds to a pair of
genealogists and any in any cycling
around in here that's not going to
change that so it's the set of runs
through the strongly connected component
graph that gives you audio genealogies
so if you just an AMA rating than that
so if you have now let's forget it it's
you run through this so you make you
make this strongly connected component
graph and then all the runs through that
in nominating those that's all your
transitions in the hidden Markov model
because that corresponds to a left than
right genealogy so you really want to
sum of all the possibilities of what's
going on between these jumps from one in
genealogy to another and if you build
your hidden mark on wall you also want
to discretize time and we've tried it a
few different things the one thing that
works out nicely when you want to write
a computer program to do it is to think
about the discretization as
I'm points where I know which strongly
connected component I'm in so we don't
keep track of when or in which interval
anything like that
you jump between the strongly connected
components we just keep track off which
component am i in at tau 1 tau 2 tau 3
and so on so that's that's something we
want to do for the discretized time in
this and then you want to sum over all
the possible paths you go through
between these so you know that I'm in
component 1 here and component 2 here I
need to sum of all the possible path of
going from component 1 to component
component 2 but the big graph they're
not the connected component graph but
the original one that's really just the
rate matrix in a continuous-time markov
chain so you can take the time
difference here multiplied so that rate
matrix exponentiation and then sum over
all the states in component one and all
the states in component two and then you
have the integration over all possible
switches going from component one to
component two in this time interval so
really if it boils down to taking this
huge graph translate it into them into a
matrix and then tossing some numerical
library added to get the scale all the
probabilities just so move all over your
state and this is a way of saying oh by
the way do dynamic programming is one to
solve it and this is an example of it I
have 15 minutes left right yeah so if
you if we're back to just having our two
are two genes then the probability of
going from them coalescing within some
interval I that means that below here I
need to know that they're in component
not tallest and up here that in
component coalesced those are the two
I have well they could also of cornice
on the left and not on the right or on
the left if I want to say that they're
both coil is e ni I need to sum over all
the states where they haven't coalesced
on the left or the right up to this
point and then sum of all the
possibilities of having coalesced at
this point so that's just the same song
as the previous slide but concretely
four four four four two and if I want to
say the probability of coalescing on the
left in interval I on the right
J well again you sum of all these
components at this point you have to sum
of all the states with a having to list
and at this point you have to sum of all
those where they've caught is on the
left and up here you have to sum of all
those by they're only coalesced in the
left but up here that must have
coalesced on both and your sum of all
and it's not hard to imagine that we can
get a computer program to do all these
solving over States and building the
graphs and everything like that quite
quite quite easily and this is the this
is the algorithm this is how we how we
built the transition matrices in these
in these hidden Markov models that's how
you construct the state spaces based on
your configuration on how many
populations to have how many samples do
you have from each is the migration yes
or no one things like that that builds
this ctmc
so you chop that into a library and
exponentiate it that gives you all the
transition probabilities and then you
need to sum over all the paths in the
strongly connected component graphs that
gives you those things you have to fill
into a transition matrix and all this of
course is done automatically except that
the number of states and the number of
transitions really explodes very very
quickly if you just say how many samples
do I have within a single population
this is how the number of states grow
and the number of transitions which is
hard really to to see how bad it is but
if you plot it it looks pretty bad and
if you look at the transitions it looks
very bad
yeah and then if you have more more
population so need to keep track of that
and how they jump between with migration
it gets very nasty very quickly so even
though we can do it all automatically
the computer can't so we need a better
computer but we've played around with
with it a bit just taking to Sam so
we've looked at some polar bears I'm
going to skip that because I'm actually
many things run out of time even though
I didn't prepare that much we've looked
at great apes Rango tanks gorillas
bonobos and chimps humans and chimps
looked at models with and without
migration we think there's been long
periods of some gene flow we can
actually tell apart and mix the advance
or a long period with the same rate of
off gene flow but we think that's been
gene flow for Marengo tanks the gorillas
we we don't see anything between Peru
Busan and chimpanzees we do see
something between humans and chimpanzees
in that in that split I've actually
looked at all of the great apes and all
the results are in here with both so the
stuff that says Cole hmm he was actually
the pairwise call hmm the stuff that
says I Ellis it's also a call hmm there
were three three leaders so so we've
estimated these effective population
sizes and spit times and things like
that Authority great apes and then I
wanted to talk about cool stuff you
could do with migration I haven't
managed to get it to work so I will talk
about something else which is not really
my results that I'm in here somewhere in
the authors list but it's actually
Casper Monken and big issue up from from
from from from O's and it's our most
recent paper using correlations and
since they are not here to present it I
will just say a few words about it
because I think it's pretty cool the
idea is since we are modeling these
changing genealogies along the along the
genome anyway we can go in and decode
that just stand up a hidden Markov model
posterior decoding and then we can see
along the genome which the analogy I win
that means we can also see when do you
swiftly switch from one gene energy to
another to a third and so on the only
way you can switch between them is to
recombinations or a bug in the code but
let's assume that it's recombinations so
you can count how many changes do you
see in a certain window and that is it's
a rate of three combinations and if you
look at the humans and chimps and
gorillas if you try to work out when in
time to the east recombination to occur
because recombinations that happened
down here they would have split apart
the chromosome up here you coolness back
in again recombinations that happen
close to this point or in here you can
see you can also see if you appear
because there you have three genealogies
you can jump between and if you simulate
it actually you can also do the math and
get the get the same results you will
see that these are where there's
actually a big grey area here that you
can't see but that's human chimpanzee
answers so that's in here these are
recover recombination events that
happens in the chimpanzee or the human
that we can see as changing geology the
gene elegies in the ancestor these
things that are happening in - in the
gorillas and these are what's happening
later and if you just take the numbers
you can see that the changes and gene
elegies we see the 61 percent of them
happened in the ancestor of human and
chimpanzees there's only a little that's
happening
this bronze bronze here and here and the
previous slide show you that if they
happen on this bronze they actually
happen up happening up here they're not
they're not from down here so the
changes in genealogies we see actually a
recombinations in the ancestor so but
just tell me these things you get a map
of where the recombinations occurred but
those you observe of them anyway I mean
could be biased in the ancestor we're
not seeing them it's not reasonable ones
now you can take that and compare it
yeah these are simulations if we take
our parameters and simulate so you how
much information do you think you have
of the period before the spent
populations because in principle this is
a type of information about that kind of
black zone before or recently than the
human Jim Smith right you're seeing
recombination events
yes I mean we are serving and so the
this is where the I'm in time and this
is how many of them see we're seeing but
we're not really seeing a lot of
recombination so maybe that too far part
three - tell us anything about it yes
yeah yeah I mean it's not a huge number
I think we're seeing a million or
something we can always discuss what we
can't learn that anything between one or
two million years and six million years
ago until we stop being a [ __ ] in
we can just look at symmetries simply
the recombination information you're
having the sites it's very exciting
and we can see that we companies is that
scaling on its going to know it's going
to affect it a lot because I mean
essentially that the question is how
long will the recombination event
survive until it cornices again and if
you if you're chugging a bottle neck in
there then nothing
so so it is very since then these
numbers fits a constant population size
if we assume that right after the speech
at the same size we infer today if you
fill the wrong with that
everything changes completely a
bottleneck right after the speciation
it's probably Katrina for the
recombination is happening on that farms
and every knology goes on the other
that's very cool yeah we haven't done it
I don't think you I think you'll just
see that as a different effective
relations as I'm being done yeah I'm
pretty sure if you decrease it in one
species and increase it the same amount
in the other you end up with the same
number of recommendations yeah we break
the symmetry with the gorillas coming in
so maybe you can do something bad
because then there would be difference
in how often are you well maybe they
were I think that what you know I think
it's an asymmetry in how long are they
how long are the stretches where you
have gorillas and chimps
I think those would be
yeah
I think last time we looked at this we
were looking at not the full genomes I
don't think all the questions okay so we
are assuming that if there's hit sites
down here they will have coalesced up
here so whenever you have a head site
you can pick any of them
and if you pick them randomly you should
be fine so so I mean this this falls
apart if you have a lot of share put
them off isn't right so if you have a
sizeable fraction of the head size down
here actually being putting off about
the air falls apart but you need the
size there is actually a problem with
going as high as you want all the
computations are for figuring out all
the stuff I told you is figuring out
that the passed through the strongly
connected component round that that's
the hard part
after that these songs yeah I mean you
need to sum over States and more more
than the discretized fine finally but
the explosion is not there if you could
build that the ctmc it's not a problem
adding a million time engines of course
you can't go there with four sequences
it's a strange
more questions